Do you ever wonder why some high school or college dropouts make it big out there,
but valedictorians rarely make history?
Intelligence is something that isn't always easily spotted
Sometimes,
it means more than simply getting an A on a test,
or receiving your diploma
There's a difference between being a life-long learner,
and jumping through the academic hoops just to get by in life
Wondering where you fall with your abilities?
Here are five signs you're highly intelligent
1. You're not afraid to ask questions
Smart people rarely just follow the status quo without questioning it
In fact,
it's usually those that don't want to think, that they do what they're told
because asking the "why"s requires extra brain power
But if you've got a rebellious streak to you,
and you're curious about the world you live in,
then you might be smarter than you actually think you are!
Unfortunately, not every workplace or classroom nurtures this idea
In fact, some leaders enjoy feeling in control
by leading those who know less than them
Don't fall in this trap, and embrace your inquisitive nature
2. You tend to be self critical
Narcissists like to project their own reality onto others
and don't feel remorse when they lie to others
about how good they are at something
But intelligent people know how to
acknowledge their own faults, flaws, and weaknesses
Instead of trying to impress others with their abilities,
intelligent people can be quite humble and critique themselves,
often looking for ways to self-improve
3. You love projects!
Do you like reading up DIY ideas,
watching videos on new recipes,
or enjoy repairing your home?
People who are intelligent, love to keep busy
They rarely call it a day after they clock out from work
and enjoy immersing themselves with fun activities that boost their knowledge
Just like going to the gym for a physical workout,
smart people need their daily brain exercise
Whether it means learning a new language,
taking dance lessons,
or attending art classes
intelligent people know how to fill up their schedules and minds
4. You're messy
This is definitely one I can relate to
Do you have a messy room or workplace?
Turns out there's more going on than just clutter
According to a study published in Psychological Science by the University of Minnesota
48 participants were asked to come up with unusual uses for a ping pong ball
The 24 individuals working in neat rooms
came up with less creative responses
than those who worked in messy rooms
So the next time your mom scolds you for not making your bed,
let her know it's hurting your creativity
5. You don't think that you're smart
This is called the Dunning Kruger Effect,
in which people with low level of competence tend to overestimate their ability
Whereas, highly competent individuals tend to sell themselves short
Why is this?
Intelligent people realize just how much room there is to improve
and they're never satisfied with their current knowledge level
Always hungry for more information,
their brain appetite grows with each new set of skills they pick up
Do you resonate with these signs?
Please share your thoughts with us below
Remember, intelligence doesn't have to be limited, unless you allow it
Everyone has the ability to grow
Also, don't forget to subscribe to Psych2go
for more helpful tips and share this video with others
Thanks so much for watching!